this video is brought to you by recon
recon make great air birds with a great
sounds at an affordable price points
they're all about in aversive earbud
designs at prices that don't break the
bank so they sent me this pair of every
day 25 earbuds and I've been using them
for a couple of days now they easily fit
in my ear my ears are kind of weird
shapes that's nice they deliver six
hours of play time the bluetooth pairing
just works which is nice because
normally bluetooth pairing can be a bit
of a pain in the ass plus they come in
this case and what this does is it
charges the ear buds so as well as that
six hours of playtime you pop them in
there it charges them four more times
now I've used cheap air buds I've used
expensive air buds for TRACON Zoo is
they deliver a premium experience at
about half the price of other premium
wireless earbuds so just go to buy recon
comm forward slash visit ikh and you'll
get 15% off your order and let's get
into today's video
[Applause]
[Music]
for years maiden China was synonymous
with cheap and cheerful for example
Chinese mobiles are cheaper than iPhones
or Samsung models however few Chinese
companies have pioneered any new
technology until now Huawei is still the
leader on 5g commercial contracts we're
talking about 5g that is very high-speed
mobile Internet
to give you an idea of just how quick it
is 5g is 20 times faster than 4G and
that doesn't just help visual politic
videos load faster on your mobile phone
for example 5g is going to be critical
for us to be able to get used to fully
self-driving cars
and I know what you're gonna be thinking
while way but don't they just make
mobile phones
well yes but they also manufacture the
antennas and all the necessary hardware
to assemble Internet networks that is
every time you use the internet from
your phone you're connecting to the
nearest antenna typically these antennas
paid for by mobile phone operators ie
companies such as Oh to Vodafone or AT&T
but these companies don't make antennas
antenna manufacturers can be brands like
Nokia Alcatel or of course far away well
in this new race for 5g Huawei is the
leading company and you might be
thinking well that's great Simon
congratulations to our way who cares
well that depends on who you ask for
example this is what Donald Trump thinks
Huawei is something that's very
dangerous you look at what they've done
from a security standpoint from a
military standpoint it's very dangerous
think about it hallway is a Chinese
company as you know in China the line
between governments and business is very
blurred and we're talking about
installing Internet networks for an
entire city or a whole country that is
Trump is afraid that China might spy on
Americans using their phones so is Trump
right or not well again it depends on
who you ask because across the Atlantic
the UK really does want quar away and
that's not all Boris Johnson even sent
this message to Trump if people oppose
one brand or other then they have to
tell us which is the alter what's the
alternative so the question is how is it
that a Chinese company is leading the
five G race is this a problem or not and
more importantly is China really gonna
spy on us well today we're gonna answer
those questions but before we do let's
take a look back at the history
[Music]
unprofitable technology in 2009 Oslo and
Stockholm were the first two cities to
deploy 4G networks
[Music]
[Applause]
a few years later almost everyone has a
4G connection the speed and quality of
that connection is what has allowed
video calls the success of social
networks the explosion of YouTube and
commerce and the question is what's 5g
gonna bring us while 5g is a
telecommunications standard it is
defined by the international
telecommunication union which is a UN
body for 5g technology they established
several requirements we must offer
download speeds of at least 20 gigabits
per second response times of less than
one millisecond and technology capable
of connecting at least 1 million devices
in one square kilometer so what does all
this mean well mainly within that
million devices we won't just have
mobile phones we're also talking about
self-driving cars factories and even
houses it's the future and if anyone can
tell us about it it's Renjie Zhang Fei
Huawei's boss in the next 20 or 30 years
we will see a great technological
revolution where we will become an
information society automated by
artificial intelligence in the era of
cloud and AI we will see explosive
growth in data bursting forth like a
tsunami this data leads the support of
the most advanced equipment possible in
other words no one disputes that 5g is
very good but the question is is it
really worth it or put it another way
how much is it gonna cost well let me
give an example Spain at the moment
Spain has 90,000 3G and 4G antennas each
antenna costs about eighty seven
thousand five hundred dollars you can
get the calculator out right now if you
think those antennas sound expensive
well bear in mind that 5g is gonna be
even more so you see mobile networks use
high frequency waves known as millimeter
waves 5g requires these waves to have
the best frequency possible to transmit
a higher volume of data
problem is that these waves have more
difficulty crossing obstacles which
makes more antennas necessary and I know
what you're thinking what difference
does it really make it's a safe
investment we all want faster Internet
I'm sure the operators are going to line
up for 5g and my response that would be
a yes sure because it doesn't seem that
clear at all the truth is most traders
barely make money with 4G in fact it is
only now 10 years later when they're
starting to recoup their investments
think about 5g will allow you to
download a movie in seconds question is
do you really need to download a movie
in seconds I mean with 4G you can
already see it in a few minutes and is
it really that much of a difference the
same goes for self-driving cars yes they
are fantastic they are going to be a
revolution this have you seen any yet so
far we're really just talking about
experiments in other words most things
that really require 5g don't yet exist
yet the technology is wonderful but
sometimes getting too far ahead of
yourself can be very expensive take the
example of the Tokyo Olympics
yes I know because a coronavirus they're
not going to be held until 2021 but if
they had been held in 2020 it would have
been the first major event broadcast in
8k and yes maybe you didn't know that 8k
technology is a thing and it's anything
but cheap however I'm sure you're
probably watching it on your TV at home
in HD because most people haven't even
moved on to 4k that means that Japan is
going to spend a fortune on some things
that almost no one will notice
so well I suppose that area for Japan
all this explains why European countries
like nor Alcatel have hardly invested in
5g they've basically said ah 5g is the
future but we'll look into it tomorrow
because but doing something else right
now but in China they have done the
opposite why well let's take a look at
that right now
[Music]
article seven
in rare cases China has been as
transparent as it has in deciding the
developing 5gs priority and you know how
Beijing works with its five-year plans
they have a centralized economy and they
have said let's go for it
so the communist regime has moved
everything quickly so that hallway one
of its flagship companies in the
telecommunications sector is investing
in 5g have they done it well as they
said in Jurassic Park
we haven't spared any expense
state support helped fuel always global
rise china's tech champion got as much
as seventy five billion dollars in tax
breaks financing and cheap resources as
it became the world's top telecom vendor
today Huawei is known by all of us but
you should know that this is a private
company that began in 1987 so it has
been able to benefit from a double boom
the telecommunications boom and the boom
in China's economy Huawei managed to
take hold of the huge Chinese market and
deliver them fully fledged
communications from virtually nothing
it is currently second in the world for
selling the most mobile phones more than
200 million
however selling smartphones is only half
of its business the other half is the
development of mobile networks and
they're not doing so badly Huawei is the
undisputed market leader in 5g it has
reached a 30% global market share and
now you'll be thinking well where is the
problem with a Chinese company or
leading the world market it is what
globalization does and China is just one
more competitor the problem is when we
take a look at Chinese law we find
things like this
any organization or citizen shall
support assist and cooperate with the
state intelligence were in importance
with the law article 7 of the National
Intelligence law 2017 whoa yes even if
Huawei denies it it is clear that the
Chinese government can force you to spy
obviously there are fears that this
could happen in the West but there's
something even more dangerous in a
hypothetical serious conflict between
China and any other country using
huawei's mobile network equipment the
biggest risk is no longer that Huawei
will spy on you think about it in a
world with cars connected to the
Internet factories connected to the
Internet even hospitals connected to the
Internet what if China controlled all of
that in a war
[Music]
yes I know you're thinking while Simon
this sounds like a mixture of sci-fi and
a ridiculous conspiracy theory and oh
yeah it may seem unthinkable but there
have already been a number of
governments that are taking it very
seriously and we're not just talking
about Donald Trump Japan latest country
to exclude Huawei ZTE from 5g rollout
over security concerns however in Europe
they're not so clear why well look at
this Boris Johnson's move in Europe
there are powerful companies to develop
mobile networks Ericsson is Swedish
Nokia is finish what's more many of
these companies also have their own 5g
systems but of course China is going as
another speed China already has 5g
coverage in 50 cities with 150,000 base
stations running by the way Wuhan is
among them let's hold on for a minute
because Chinese operators don't stop
[Music]
this year they're going to be investing
25 billion euros to raise five G
coverage to 330 cities thanks to more
than 500,000 base stations so saying no
to huawei technology comes at a price it
could mean that 5g arrives two years
late and okay yes China does have laws
that could force Huawei to spy but there
are two things we cannot forget the
first is that Huawei has been operating
in Europe for two decades that's right
many of the antennas that connect your
mobile to the world are made by Huawei
and at the moment has no proof that
they're spying
and what's the secondly we can't forget
well take a look at this map this is the
map of countries with backdoor laws that
is in all the countries that you see
read the government can force a service
operator to let you see messages these
laws were made to be able to investigate
terrorists the United States has laws of
this kind France and the United Kingdom
as well and to know are you gonna tell
me well let's see Simon being spied on
by a communist dictatorship is not the
same as being spied on by a democracy
and of course he absolutely rights but
at this point to what extent are we
talking about security or economic
xenophobia
[Music]
I mean what's the real problem that
China may spy on us or having a Chinese
company compete at the top of the fields
and it's not just about ethics we're
talking about money at the moment Huawei
has the most modern and cheapest 5g how
much cheaper well on average it's 20%
less than European alternatives so the
UK has sought a formula to have the
cutting edge cell network technology
that Huawei offers while saving a lot of
pounds and not provoking the anger of
Donald Trump
[Music]
and yes the latter will be the most
complicated because the UK belongs to
the five eyes Alliance five eyes is a
pact that includes the United States
Canada the United Kingdom Australia and
New Zealand
this alliance monitors the security of
electronic communications of these five
countries the United Kingdom is the only
one who works with Huawei and you'll say
well what's going on here as Boris
Johnson gone mad has he been bribed
well no none of that's quite the
opposite the UK has been watching Huawei
very closely for 10 years in fact in
2010 the cybersecurity Assessment Center
was created very close to Oxford so what
conclusions have they reached well the
only thing they've criticised in the
past 10 years is that the software could
have been better programs but come on
that's what happens do any
telecommunications company oh and by the
way they found absolutely nothing
related to espionage all this explains
why Johnson has turned a deaf ear to
pressure from the United States because
it turns out that Washington is going
around threatening to cut off all
intelligence collaboration with any
countries in which Huawei supply is 5g
but Boris Johnson master of unlikely
deals after getting brexit has found a
5g formula in the UK that ensures that
neither China nor the US could be
troubled by Downing Street
okay will allow huawei to supply 5g with
tight restrictions the UK has decided to
exclude Huawei computers from the core
the so-called network or in other words
quoi wave will not be used to service 5g
government communications military bases
nuclear power plants etc that is to
anything deemed critical security
[Music]
however highway equipment can be used on
the antennas that make up the network
structure which supply homes and
businesses however they will never be
more than 35% of the network for each of
the operators thanks to this move by
Johnson the UK can have 5g 2 years in
advance make a positive impact on its
economy amounting to 7 billion pounds
and have Trump's anger reduced to an
arguments over the phone
meanwhile the United States is still
trying to pull out its own 5g
alternative for while that's a story for
another video so now the question goes
over to you do you think Boris Johnson
is right to left Huawei install its 5g
mobile networks in the UK or are you
more of trumps point-of-view leave your
answer please in the comments below and
I really do hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please do hit that like
button don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also please do check
out our friends at the Ricans at a media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode but we're not mine and as always
thank you for watching and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast see you there
[Music]